>> UKRAINE'S DEFENSE MINISTER
SAYS HIS TROOPS ARE SET TO
BEGIN TRAINING ON LEOPARD TANKS
IN GERMANY.
SEVERAL NATO ALLIES HAVE
DONATED THE GERMAN TANKS TO
UKRAINE.
TRAINING IS EXPECTED TO LAST
TWO OR THREE MONTHS.
IT COMES AS RUSSIA IS BELIEVED
TO BE PREPARING FOR ANOTHER
OFFENSIVE.
MORE ON THIS STORY, I'M JOINED
BY NICK ROBERTSON WHO'S IN
ESTONIA.
NICK, SO MUCH ATTENTION ON THE
LEOPARD TANKS THESE DAYS.
WHAT MORE DID YOU LEARN?
>> YEAH, WHEAT MILITARY
EXERCISE HERE BY NATO.
1500 TROOPS, OVER 500 VEHICLES,
44 TANKS.
THE DANISH LEOPARD 2 TANK,
GERMAN MADE OF COURSE, VERY
SIMILAR TO THOSE THAT WILL BE
SENT TO UKRAINE, BRITISH
CHALLENGER 2 TANKS HERE AS
WELL.
THOSE TANKS GOING TO UKRAINE.
SO THE LESSONS THAT UKRAINE CAN
LEARN FROM THESE MILITARY
TRAINING EXERCISES HERE THAT,
BY THE WAY, ARE JUST 170
KILOMETERS FROM THE RUSSIAN
BORDER, ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE THIS NATO MILITARY
EXERCISE PUTS TOGETHER THE
TANKS AND THE INFANTRY SO THEY
CAN PUNCH THROUGH AND BE BITES
AND TRY TO TAKE TERRITORY.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT UKRAINIANS
WANT TO DO WITH THESE TANKS.
>> DANISH LEOPARD 2 TANKS,
SIMILAR TO THOSE SOON TO BE
DEPLOYED TO UKRAINE, STORMING
THINNED IMAGINED ENEMY POSITION
IN ESTONIA.
FRENCH TROOPS ATTACK FOR --
FICTIONAL FRONTLINES.
AS IS TONY IN TROOPS PRETEND TO
HOLD THEM OFF.
IT'S ALL PART OF THE BALTIC
NATIONS ANNUAL NATO WINTER
EXERCISE, TO GEL THE
MULTINATIONAL ALLIANCE INTO A
SINGULAR FIGHTING FORCE.
THIS YEAR, THE MILITARY
EXERCISES FEEL DIFFERENT.
THE FRENCH HAVE BROUGHT IN FAR
MORE TROOPS THAN THE PAST, AND
WITH MORE --
WAR STILL RAGING A FARAWAY IN
UKRAINE, COMMANDERS SAY THE
TRAINING FEELS MUCH MORE REAL.
TWO THIRDS OF THE 44 TANKS
INVOLVED IN THE EXERCISE OUR
BRITISH CHALLENGER 2 TANKS.
MORE LIKE THESE ALSO SEEM TO
POINT TO UKRAINE.
LESSONS LEARNED HERE, VALUABLE
FOR THE UKRAINIANS.
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE
CHALLENGER AND LEOPARD TANKS
ARE CRITICAL, BUT NO DOUBT USED
CORRECTLY THEY COULD BE A
GAME-CHANGER.
BOTH CAN DO --
CAN FIGHT AT NIGHT, THEY HAVE
HUNTER KAYLOR CAPABILITIES AS
WELL.
THEY CAN ENGAGE A TARGET WHILE
LOOKING FOR THEIR NEXT TARGET.
MUCH MORE ADVANCED TANKS AND
ADVANCED CITING SYSTEMS THAN
THEY WOULD HAVE.
>> THE UKRAINIANS SAY THEY WANT
TO USE THE LEVER TO PAINT AS AN
IRON FIST TO PUNCH THROUGH
RUSSIAN LINES AND GIVE PUTIN A
BLOODY NOSE.
AND ALSO BACK TERRITORY THEY
HAVE LOST.
>> THE LESSON HERE IS THAT
WON'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
TYPICALLY, DANES TRAIN
INDIVIDUAL LEOPARD 2 OPERATORS
IN TWO WEEKS, A CREW OF FOUR IN
TWO MONTHS.
IT CAN TAKE TWO YEARS HOWEVER
TO COMBINE THEM INTO A VOICE
ABLE TO SEIZE TERRITORY.
>> IT'S THE TACTICS THAT TAKE
TIME.
THEN YOU HAVE A THEORY AS A
CREW.
THEN YOU HAVE TO LEARN TO DRIVE
AS A CREW.
WITHIN THE PLATOON'S.
>> ESTONIA'S DEFENSE MINISTER,
WHICH COUNTRY SPENDS A WHOPPING
1% OF GDP SUPPORTING UKRAINE,
WATCHING THE TRAINING, KEEN TO
GET THE TANKS TO UKRAINE
SOONEST.
>> I REALLY HOPE THAT IT'S NOT
TOO LATE.
I REALLY HOPE IT BECAUSE WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A PUSH
FROM RUSSIANS COMING IN A VERY,
LIKE, THE COMING MONTHS, FOR
COMING WEEKS EVEN.
>> IS THIS A MAKE-OR-BREAK
MOMENT IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS?
>> PROBABLY.
ONCE AGAIN, IF THERE IS NO
BREAKTHROUGH IN THE COMING
WEEKS OR MONTHS, AND PROBABLY
WE WILL STEP INTO A VERY LONG
TIME OF WAR.
>> THIS OPERATION ONGOING FOR
ANOTHER WEEK, AS ELSEWHERE
UKRAINIAN TROOPS BEGIN TO GET
THEIR HANDS ON PIECES LIKE
THESE.
HOW QUICKLY THEY CAN USE THEM
EFFECTIVELY WILL IMPACT WELL
BEYOND UKRAINE.
I'M JUST GOING TO STEP OUT OF
THE WAY HERE SO YOU CAN SEE
SOME OF THE REFUELING THAT IS
GOING ON HERE.
THIS IS A LEOPARD 2 TANK THAT
IS GETTING REFUELLED OUT IN THE
FIELD HERE.
THERE'S BRITISH CHALLENGER 2
THANKS GETTING REFUELLED.
BUT TANKS HERE ALL HEADED OFF
INTO THE WOODS, PART OF THE
EXERCISE.
THEY WILL BE HIDING OUT IN THE
WOODS AS COMMANDOES TRIED TO
FIND THEM THROUGH THE NIGHT.
THE BIG TAKEAWAY FOR THE
UKRAINIANS I THINK IS THAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE BIG LOGISTICAL
SUPPLY AND SUPPORT.
YOU NEED THE MOBILE FUEL
VEHICLES.
YOU NEED THE ENGINEERING TEAMS
AS WELL TO BE AVAILABLE TO THE
TANK COMMANDERS.
WE SPOKE TO A BRITISH TANK
OFFICER HERE WHO SAID HIS TEAM
'S, IF ONE OF THE CHALLENGER
TANKS BREAKS DOWN, THEY CAN
LITERALLY CHANGE OUT THE WHOLE
ENGINE AND GEARBOX IN ABOUT AN
HOUR.
THAT'S VITAL TO KEEP THIS HEAVY
ARMOR IN BATTLE, ENGAGED IN THE
FIGHT.
SO AGAIN, THIS IS ALL SKILLS
AND EQUIPMENT THAT UKRAINIAN
FORCES ARE GOING TO NEED TO GET,
BUT THE FACT THEY'VE STARTED
THE TRAINING IS SIGNIFICANT.
THE CONCERN OF ESTONIA'S
DEFENSE MINISTER VERY CLEAR.
IF THE UKRAINIANS CANNOT MAKE
GAINS THIS YEAR, THEN THE WAR
STUTTERS INTO AN ONGOING DRAWN
OUT PROTRACTED TRENCH WARFARE
POTENTIALLY.
AND DURING THAT TIME, THE
SUPPORT FROM ALLIED NATIONS TO
UKRAINE, THERE'S A REAL DANGER
THAT COULD BEGIN TO FALL AWAY.
SO THE PRESSURE IS REALLY ON.
GET THE TANKS INTO THE HANDS OF
UKRAINIANS, AND GET THEM
PROPERLY TRAINED TO USE THEM
EFFECTIVELY.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT, NIC,
BOTH THE EQUIPMENT AND
PERSONNEL NECESSARY.
THANKS, NIC.